so today we are trying hot cheeto
infused tequila which we saw on tipsy
bartender I'm into hot cheetos I'm into
alcohol
am i into hot cheetos and alcohol I love
hot cheetos I don't like tequila shot we
both like the food and top yeah maybe
they'll like cancel each other out you
said there will be hot cheetos and you
know this girl loves hot cheetos and
then I saw the tequila I doesn't write I
thought this is gonna be like just like
a spicy margarita show with the kilo yes
almost YC McGregor's made for them to
keep up shows my drag all knowledge all
right let's look at it started so we're
taking this Mesa dinner and we're
filling it halfway with hot cheetos I
didn't wash my hands
[Music]
let's shake it
[Music]
this would be a great pal Enger oh my
god that is I just don't want diarrhea
that's all okay we got time I can't
prepare it actually chiz Oh Oh No
it tastes exactly what it looks like oh
my god that was disgusting I head up and
agree oh no that you know it well give
me a I like the aftertaste of spice
though because I really like spicy foods
and spicy drink besides you like that
nice little feeling in my throat for the
actual short take it is pretty gross
this would be like if you were stuck on
Everest and you were freezing take a hot
cheeto shot warm you right up girl it
was one shot I like that my identity
what I was it was like drinking
something that told your soul hey you
suck we had a different thing you livin
bad yeah it was definitely better than
tequila alone for sure sorry two
kilometres I know that's like you're
rolling in your grave and I kind of like
spicy
burns out there if I wasn't a pigeon I
wanted to make a cocktail for someone we
all we had was Decatur and Hot Cheetos
I'd make it I don't have any mixer but I
have
[Music]